Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child a baby in the house.
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我家里有一个孩子了。
Do you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
你知道我觉得什么很难做到吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Eat food, yes that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
吃东西，是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know and I forget.
我知道，但我忘记了。
It's like, oh I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，我不会，没有必要，没有大惊小怪，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes.
是的。
And so what would solve that problem?
那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meets Lil' Lamb, Yeager, Snacksticks?
哦，等等，你是在谈论巴伐利亚遇见 Lil' Lamb、Yeager、Snacksticks 吗？
The agreed that's what right before we started talking to Zoe said that's what we're going to talk about.
在我们开始与佐伊交谈之前，我们就同意这就是我们要讨论的内容。
Well this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想谈的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, Lil' Lan Yeager, Snacksticks, they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life which is I forget to eat.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类、Lil' Lan Yeager、零食棒，他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy.
另外，我有一个19岁的男孩。
Also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home.
这也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会把我们吃得满屋子和家里。
And he loves this stuff.
他喜欢这个东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got, we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们得到了这个，我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is gonna eat it all.
我儿子会把它全部吃掉。
I'm gonna have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds.
但没关系，无论您是在赶会议还是在给婴儿或 19 岁的孩子喂奶，它都是一款适合您一天的零食。
Doing school drop-off, just trying to finish your to-do list.
送学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单。
Take a moment to save or something delicious for you or your children.
花点时间为您或您的孩子保存一些美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable?
我们有没有提到它们是便携式的？
toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包中或任何地方扔一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Better up to two or three of those bad boys.
最好是两个或三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother10mother10 at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结帐时使用代码 mother10mother10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The variant meat snack, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
变种肉零食，棒，味道好，零糖。
I can talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do.
我们确实这么做了。
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量，或者健身平台只是压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy, testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多项健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
With in days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
For your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother to save up to 15% on select tests that's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code Mother.
对于您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother，在 ondemand.labcore.comlash mother 并使用代码 Mother 的精选测试中可节省高达 15% 的费用。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
Hey, I'm Josh Radner and I am joined as ever by my dear friend Craig Thomas.
嘿，我是乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner），我亲爱的朋友克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）一如既往地加入了我的行列。
Hello Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hello Craig.
你好克雷格。
It's great to see you again.
很高兴再次见到你。
This is a bonus episode of how we made your mother and it's something we like to call general questions, general questions.
这是我们如何创造你母亲的额外一集，我们喜欢将其称为一般问题，一般问题。
So we're joined also by our pal and producer Alec Lev.
我们的朋友兼制片人亚历克·列夫也加入了我们的行列。
Hello, Alec.
你好，亚历克。
Oh, Josh.
哦，乔什。
Hello.
你好。
Do you have any general questions for us?
您有任何一般性问题要问我们吗？
Lamb honest, my man.
羔羊诚实，我的朋友。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
All right.
好的。
You missed your salute, Craig.
你错过了你的敬礼，克雷格。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
Excellent.
出色的。
I was never in the army.
我从未参过军。
I never will be in the army.
我永远不会参军。
Yeah, hi guys.
是的，大家好。
This week, people are curious, I would say, in the large about how TV kind of gets made.
我想说，本周，人们对电视是如何制作的非常好奇。
There's a lot of questions.
有很多问题。
By the way, this is about episode three, sweet taste of liberty.
顺便说一下，这是第三集《自由的甜蜜滋味》。
These are questions about episode three, right?
这些是关于第三集的问题，对吧？
It is.
这是。
That is correct.
这是正确的。
There were a lot of questions about liberty bells and licking things and we're going to focus more on the production side of things.
关于自由钟和舔东西有很多问题，我们将更多地关注事情的生产方面。
I'm just going to give you a couple examples, but then I'm going to broaden out the question.
我只想给你们举几个例子，然后我将扩大这个问题的范围。
So LJ no LJ Spectrum asks how far into filming did you create the opening sequence and bar photos?
所以LJ no LJ Spectrum问你拍摄开场镜头和酒吧照片时进行了多长时间？
Was it specifically for this episode and then turned into the opening montage?
是专门为了这一集然后变成开场蒙太奇吗？
How did you do that?
你是怎么做到的？
And then Oscar underscore Cal Vajor says just out of curiosity is this the same basement we see later on at Stella's house.
然后奥斯卡强调卡尔·瓦乔出于好奇说这就是我们后来在斯特拉家看到的同一个地下室。
So just thinking about how yeah I don't know, but the answer to that or I've never actually seen the show.
所以只是想，是的，我不知道，但答案是我从来没有真正看过这个节目。
I don't have any.
我没有。
Obviously we have we have viewers who know a lot more than we do.
显然，我们有比我们了解更多的观众。
But I think what this is going to is just kind of how do make a television show.
但我认为这只是制作电视节目的一种方式。
And I think if we can walk through one thing, we'll answer a lot of people's questions.
我认为如果我们能够解决一件事，我们就能回答很多人的问题。
And maybe we could do a helium style of how did Craig see a week of production and how did Josh see a week of production?
也许我们可以做一个氦气风格的克雷格如何看待一周的制作以及乔什如何看待一周的制作？
How was this show made?
这个节目是怎么制作的？
Can I go back to a thing?
我可以回到一件事吗？
Because I actually, I really like the first question is about the open credit sequence.
因为我实际上非常喜欢第一个问题是关于开放信用顺序的。
Me too.
我也是。
Great.
伟大的。
So, and we can get back to this out because I like this too.
所以，我们可以回到这个话题，因为我也喜欢这个。
But Craig, like where the idea for the opening credits is kind of like friends, pictures, kind of popular.
但是克雷格，就像片头的想法有点像朋友、图片一样，很受欢迎。
That was from the beginning.
从一开始就是如此。
That was when we were like writing the pilot, when the pilot got picked up.
就在我们正在写试播集的时候，试播集就被选中了。
We always had that idea.
我们一直有这个想法。
This is a weird thing that I don't think I've ever talked about.
这是一件奇怪的事情，我想我从来没有谈论过。
For a minute, I remember Carter Bay's, I think it might have been his concept to begin with.
有那么一瞬间，我想起了卡特·贝的想法，我想这可能是他最初的想法。
And the way he wanted to do it at first was pictures of just young people in New York, not even our cast.
他一开始想要的只是纽约年轻人的照片，甚至不是我们的演员。
very abstracted idea of like you're just seeing youth in New York, it could be anyone.
非常抽象的想法，就像你在纽约看到年轻人一样，它可以是任何人。
You're just seeing like this pastiche of New York City and people out and it's just them and their friends blah, blah, blah.
你看到的只是纽约市和人们的模仿，只有他们和他们的朋友等等，等等。
And I think we gained it out.
我认为我们已经成功了。
We started looking at it.
我们开始研究它。
We're like, this is too weird.
我们觉得，这太奇怪了。
Who are these people?
这些人是谁？
These aren't the same thing.
这些不是同一件事。
This is in the cast of the show.
这是这部剧的演员阵容。
And that was how we learned.
这就是我们学习的方式。
I mean, it was sort of a little too artsy of an idea, maybe.
我的意思是，这个想法也许有点太艺术化了。
And then we then we realized, let's get the cast to do this.
然后我们意识到，让演员们来做这件事。
But if I remember correctly, Josh, I think we did, we did a little photo shoot, right?
但如果我没记错的话，乔什，我想我们做到了，我们拍了一些照片，对吧？
We did a little photo shoot.
我们拍了一些照片。
We did a photo shoot right away.
我们立即拍了一张照片。
like in the booth, kind of like Candid's, I remember, Jason Holt the camera, was it like a selfie?
就像在展位上，有点像 Candid 的，我记得，Jason Holt 的相机，是不是像一张自拍照？
I think sometimes you guys were selfieing and I think sometimes literally, literally Pam Prime in our director, I think was like shooting it on at the, what at that time was like, a crappy, like disposable camera.
我想有时候你们在自拍，我想有时候真的，真的是我们导演的帕姆·普莱姆（Pam Prime），我想就像在当时的情况下拍摄，就像是一个蹩脚的一次性相机。
These were in phone packs, right?
这些是在手机包里的，对吧？
And you see that Lily, it looked, and it dates the show so much, but you see in, I mean, Ted, I'll say Lily is holding that old disposable camera.
你看，莉莉，看起来，它和这部剧很相配，但你看，我的意思是，特德，我会说莉莉拿着那台旧的一次性相机。
That's literally what they're still getting, they're placed on tables at weddings, you know, those still in use.
这就是他们现在仍然得到的东西，它们被放在婚礼的桌子上，你知道，那些仍在使用的东西。
Ironically.
讽刺的是。
Where the like color scheme come up with like that kind of seepia.
类似的配色方案会出现类似那种渗色的情况。
I really like the kind of rods and yellows and we said we wanted to feel like memories.
我真的很喜欢那种棒状和黄色，我们说我们想要感觉像回忆。
Like these sort of old tinge sort of like seepia tones sort of like just this feeling of these exist as memories in someone's mind.
就像这些古老的色调，有点像渗水的音调，就像这些感觉作为记忆存在于某人的脑海中。
Yeah.
是的。
And when did you guys hit on using the solid song or the end of Hey Beautiful?
你们什么时候开始使用这首扎实的歌曲或《Hey Beautiful》的结尾？
I think we for a minute we wanted to use it.
我想我们有一分钟想使用它。
I've never said this either.
我也从来没有说过这个。
I think we wanted to use a replacement song.
我想我们想用一首替代歌曲。
Um, the band the replacements, Carter and our huge fans of replacements, Carter turned me into a replacement span.
嗯，乐队的替补，卡特和我们的替补粉丝，卡特把我变成了替补跨度。
And we were talking about using, um, I think we're going to, I think we're going to use the song unsatisfied.
我们正在讨论使用，嗯，我想我们会，我想我们会不满意地使用这首歌。
Like, and literally, I think we cut a version of the main titles that was pictures of total strangers set to the replacement song unsatisfied.
就像，从字面上看，我认为我们剪掉了一个主要标题的版本，该版本是完全陌生的照片，设置为替换歌曲不满意。
That looks like it's just opening titles to an entirely different show called unsatisfied.
看起来这只是一个完全不同的节目《不满意》的开头。
It was utterly confusing and it was a complete fail, but it's what taught us that we needed it to be our cast.
这完全令人困惑，而且完全失败，但它告诉我们，我们需要它作为我们的演员阵容。
And the idea of photos and memories, like that was always the idea, but we had to do a bad, like misguided version of that to get to what it became.
照片和回忆的想法一直都是这个想法，但我们必须做一个糟糕的、像误导的版本才能达到它的样子。
And isn't Barney's last name after a guitar, like a replacement?
巴尼的姓氏不是跟在吉他后面的，就像一个替代品吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Barney Stinson, Stinson, Tommy Stinson is the bass player for the replacements.
Barney Stinson、Stinson、Tommy Stinson 是替补的贝斯手。
And that is a shout out to the replacements who again, and we really wanted to unsatisfied to be the song.
这是对替代者的一次大声喊叫，我们真的很想成为这首歌。
And then we got the bill for what that would cost every week.
然后我们就收到了每周的费用账单。
And then we said, what if we put our own band song on there?
然后我们说，如果我们把我们自己的乐队歌曲放在那里怎么办？
And we get that money.
我们得到了这笔钱。
And they said, what about one tenth of that money?
他们说，那十分之一的钱呢？
I said, souls.
我说，灵魂。
Craig, did you need to get approval at this point?
克雷格，此时你需要获得批准吗？
Did the studio or network have to like, look at that title sequencing?
工作室或网络是否必须喜欢看标题排序？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That thing is like tested and game down and sent up and down the chain.
那东西就像经过测试和游戏，并在链条上上下发送。
It's, it's, it's the branding of the show, right?
这是，这是，这是节目的品牌，对吧？
It's like the brand that's become so iconic.
就像这个品牌已经变得如此具有标志性。
And what's amazing about it now is like, I see people on mine, I see people on socials like them and their friends are literally shot for shot, recreating how I met your mother, photos from the opening, from the main titles, and they're doing it with their own friends.
现在令人惊奇的是，我看到我的人，我看到像他们这样的社交媒体上的人和他们的朋友一起拍摄，重现我是如何遇见你母亲的，从开头的照片，从主要标题，他们正在和自己的朋友一起做。
And I find that so moving and pointing like, we've passed this baton onto this younger generation who are now enacting it.
我发现这非常令人感动和具有指向性，我们已经将这个接力棒传递给了现在正在执行它的年轻一代。
And it's their way of saying, we're making our own memories now, I think, which is a story that Josh, you've told to about a fan, told you said, do you?
这是他们表达的方式，我想，我们现在正在创造自己的回忆，这是乔什（Josh）你告诉过一位粉丝的故事，告诉你说，是吗？
I realize I'm living these memories now.
我意识到我现在正活在这些回忆中。
And that's I love the idea that like young people watching the show are creating that themselves.
这就是我喜欢的想法，就像观看节目的年轻人正在自己创造一样。
Yeah.
是的。
So speaking of memories.
所以说到回忆。
So Josh, so at this point, we're in week three of producing this show, obviously spread over time between the pilot and the second episode.
乔希，现在我们正处于制作这部剧的第三周，显然是在试播集和第二集之间分散了时间。
But what was your week like, at least in this first season?
但你的一周过得怎么样，至少在第一季是这样？
How did that script first come to on what day rehearsal blocking?
那个剧本是怎么在哪一天排练受阻的？
How did it look for you?
你觉得怎么样？
My memory is in Craig maybe like we would get an envelope over the weekend.
我的记忆在克雷格身上，也许我们周末会收到一个信封。
Yeah, like on a Sunday, I think maybe sometimes Friday, sometimes Friday, but hard copies in a in a Manila envelope, kind of like waiting at your door.
是的，就像周日，我想有时可能是周五，有时是周五，但硬拷贝装在马尼拉信封里，有点像在门口等着。
Yeah, and you'd read and that was the table script.
是的，您已经读过，这就是表格脚本。
That was the script we were going to read Monday at like 10 a.m.
这就是我们周一上午 10 点左右要读的剧本。
Correct.
正确的。
So the actors would come in at 10 a.m.
所以演员们会在上午 10 点进来。
on Monday.
周一。
We'd sit around a table.
我们围坐在一张桌子旁。
There was a great spread of food.
有很多食物。
All the writers were there producers.
所有的编剧都是制片人。
The department heads would come to that.
部门领导会来解决这个问题。
Yeah.
是的。
And we'd sit around this.
我们会围坐在一起。
Yeah, we did.
是的，我们做到了。
This is the exact network.
这就是确切的网络。
Exactly.
确切地。
We'd sit around.
我们会坐在一起。
And it was it was not a high pressure.
而且这并不是一个高压。
I never felt beyond maybe the pilot table read.
我从来没有感觉到除了飞行员表上的读数之外。
That was always like the chillest, low pressure kind of thing.
那总是像最寒冷、低压的事情。
So we'd read the script, Pam would read the stage directions and you and Carter would flank Pam, I remember.
我记得，我们会读剧本，帕姆会读舞台指示，而你和卡特会在帕姆两侧。
And by the way, just to say counterpoint, I was wildly nervous for all two hundred and eight tables.
顺便说一句，我对所有 208 张桌子都感到非常紧张。
You were okay, miserably anxious, I shocked that you weren't.
你没事，只是非常焦虑，令我震惊的是你不是。
But think about writer brand.
但想想作家品牌。
Think about writer brand versus actor But when you read all about the script, I mean, it's about performance, but we weren't, people were listening to the script.
想想作家品牌与演员但是当你阅读所有关于剧本的内容时，我的意思是，这是关于表演的，但我们不是，人们在听剧本。
They weren't even watching us read it.
他们甚至没有看我们读它。
Yeah, yeah, they were listening to it in the air.
是啊，是啊，他们在空中听着。
It was like a radio play.
这就像一部广播剧。
To me, I'd always felt like a high stakes courtroom trial for the script.
对我来说，我一直觉得剧本就像一场高风险的法庭审判。
And like the script, the script might be like executed at the end of it.
就像脚本一样，脚本可能会在最后执行。
Like I always thought a bit in my stomach.
就像我一直在心里想的那样。
It was great when it went great, but what's the thing where writers will write down if they think a joke is good, but it was, do they just write pee for performance, like pee means punch in writers.
当事情进展顺利时，这很棒，但如果作家认为一个笑话很好，他们会写下什么，但事实是，他们只是为了表演而写尿，就像尿意味着打作家一样。
Oh, okay.
哦好的。
So what did you say where you say where you say that was the actress fault?
那么你所说的那是女演员的错是什么意思？
Not mine.
不是我的。
I don't know that there's a universal code for that.
我不知道有一个通用代码。
I heard there was something where you write in like bad line reading like good joke or something like we should say that that's also writers being fucking dicks, right?
我听说有一些东西你可以用糟糕的台词来写，比如好笑话，或者我们应该说这也是作家们他妈的混蛋，对吧？
Yeah, it was definitely the actor's fault.
是的，这绝对是演员的错。
Like, I don't know about that.
比如说，我对此一无所知。
and some writers do that.
有些作家就是这样做的。
So we would read, it would be done by 1045.
所以我们会读到，它将在 1045 年前完成。
No later than 11.
不晚于11点。
Yeah, we go home for the rest of the day.
是的，我们今天剩下的时间都回家了。
The actor's leave.
演员请假。
Yeah, I just say one thing about the table read, sorry, as someone who just sat in on some of them, you say it wasn't for the actors and for the script, certainly for me, who had no stake in this but so ever, it was a, it was such a joy to listen to the radio play version of it because you guys maybe because the pressure was so low, you guys were so loose yeah you guys were great I was having so much fun and it's the one time where the show is not about the what becomes the great direction the great production the great sound it's just about the five of you talking to each other yeah and it was hysterical it was always and to be clear it was great vibes I was anxious because I'm crazy and I'm a writer and I'm neurotic about the writing being good enough that it was the vibes were great in the room I've never been a a better table read than on a table table.
是的，我只是说关于桌子上的一件事，对不起，作为一个只是旁听其中一些人的人，你说这不是为了演员和剧本，当然是为了我，我在这方面没有利益，但所以，听广播剧版本真是一种乐趣，因为你们可能是因为压力太低了，你们太放松了，是的，你们太棒了，我玩得很开心，这是一次，这部剧不是关于什么成为伟大的方向伟大的制作，伟大的声音，就是你们五个人互相交谈，是的，这很歇斯底里，而且很明显，这是一种很棒的氛围，我很焦虑，因为我疯了，我是一名作家，我对写作是否足够好感到神经质，因为房间里的氛围很棒，我从来没有比在桌子上阅读更好的了。
Yeah.
是的。
You guys are great at it.
你们很擅长。
Loose and funny.
宽松又有趣。
It was great.
太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给纽约的你。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Josh.
乔什。
Yeah, Alec.
是的，亚历克。
You have a new baby, a new child.
你有一个新的婴儿，一个新的孩子。
He's not so new.
他并不是那么新。
Nine months?
九个月？
Is that new?
那是新的吗？
That's not that new, actually.
实际上，这并不是什么新鲜事。
So how have you started keeping track of his spending?
那么你是如何开始跟踪他的支出的呢？
We're spending on him or what he personally is spending.
我们在他身上花的钱或者他个人花的钱。
What he personally is charging at the local convenience shop at the five in dime.
他个人在当地便利店的收费是五毛钱。
Yeah, we decided it's not safe to give him money because he would, like he does with everything else we had, he would eat it.
是的，我们认为给他钱是不安全的，因为他会像对待我们拥有的其他东西一样，把钱吃掉。
To eat it in his mouth and, you know, money and coins, it's not what you want your baby eating.
把它吃到他嘴里，你知道，还有钱和硬币，这不是你想让你的宝宝吃的东西。
So we're keeping them off the money train for just a bit longer, but I imagine you have teenagers, right?
所以我们会让他们远离金钱列车一段时间，但我想你有青少年，对吗？
So you're probably in the thick of the money game with them, right?
所以你可能正与他们陷入激烈的金钱游戏，对吧？
I absolutely am.
我绝对是。
And now that their money basically exists in the netherworld of telephone version, there's no cash, right?
而现在他们的钱基本上都存在于电话版的幽冥界，没有现金吧？
You used to be, you'd give your kid cash to them, they'll run down to the chocolate shop, pick you up an egg cream.
以前，你会给你的孩子现金给他们，他们会跑到巧克力店，给你买鸡蛋奶油。
Yeah, you have no idea what this money is being spent on, but there's a solution for that.
是的，你不知道这些钱花在了什么地方，但有一个解决方案。
What's that?
那是什么？
Well, for all the parents out there with teenagers, we know you're already trying to keep a million different things under control.
好吧，对于所有有青少年的父母来说，我们知道你们已经在努力控制一百万种不同的事情。
Cash app is here to help make sure your teen's money and their spending is an adding to that craziness.
现金应用程序可以帮助确保您的孩子有钱，而他们的支出会加剧这种疯狂。
By sponsoring your teen age 13 to 17, they can get a custom cash app card set personal savings goals and even earn interest on savings with zero monthly fees.
通过赞助 13 至 17 岁的青少年，他们可以获得一张定制的现金应用卡，设定个人储蓄目标，甚至可以以零月费赚取储蓄利息。
No minimum balance and complete oversight from your account.
无最低余额限制，并由您的账户进行全面监督。
New cash app customers can earn $10 if they use code family 10 in their profile at signup and send $5 to a friend within 14 days.
如果新的现金应用程序客户在注册时使用个人资料中的代码系列 10 并在 14 天内向朋友发送 5 美元，则可以获得 10 美元。
Terms apply.
条款适用。
Cash app is a financial services platform, not a bank.
现金应用程序是一个金融服务平台，而不是银行。
Banking service is provided by Cash app's bank partners.
银行服务由 Cash app 的银行合作伙伴提供。
Prepaid debit cards issued by Sutton bank, member FDIC, cash app visa, debit flex cards issued by Sutton Bank, member FDIC, and the bank core bank NA.
Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员发行的预付借记卡、Cash App Visa、Sutton 银行、FDIC 成员和银行核心银行 NA 发行的灵活借记卡。
Pursuant to a license from VisaUSA Incorporated.
根据 VisaUSA Incorporated 的许可。
Sea terms and conditions for the Sutton prepaid card, Sutton debit flex card, and bank core debit flex card.
Sutton 预付卡、Sutton 借记灵活卡和银行核心借记灵活卡的海运条款和条件。
Savings provided by CashApp, a block incorporated brand.
由 CashApp（一个区块合并品牌）提供的节省。
Visit cash.app-legal-podcast for full disclosures.
请访问 cash.app-legal-podcast 了解完整披露信息。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh.
哦。
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist.
我的妻子乔丹娜是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师。
But today we're talking about Rula, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
但今天我们谈论的是 Rula，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer, yes, no, Rula is fantastic.
免责声明，是的，不，鲁拉太棒了。
It's a way of finding an online therapist and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on and you get to tell a little bit about what you're looking for and you get a list of therapists and they could be anywhere because this is entirely online.
你继续下去，你可以告诉你一些你正在寻找的东西，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可能在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的。
So you have a very large list and they'll tell you about themselves.
所以你有一个非常大的名单，他们会告诉你他们自己。
They have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are which is completely different from we just walk into a therapist's office.
他们有很好的简历，了解他们从事这项工作的原因、他们的兴趣、他们过去做过什么样的工作、他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同。
You're just meeting this person for the first time, and what's really great about it is you can change and you could change because the fit isn't quite right or just actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist.
你只是第一次见到这个人，真正伟大的是你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不合适，或者实际上最近我才改变，因为与一位治疗师相处了很长时间。
I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change and really makes it so easy you just go.
我只是有一种感觉，是时候做出改变了，而且真的让一切变得如此简单，你就可以走了。
You have your list of therapists and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
您有治疗师名单，您可以选择您认为最适合您的治疗师。
It almost sounds like Rula and I I hope they're okay with me saying this.
听起来就像是鲁拉和我，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somali A for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里 A 级。
It is, it's exactly what it is.
是的，就是这样。
You've got to spot what you're looking for and they say, I have a lovely, I have a lovely person in Denver, Colorado for you.
你必须找到你要找的东西，他们会说，我在科罗拉多州丹佛市有一个可爱的人在找你。
That's right, and they give you just a little bit and you just take a little sip for at first.
没错，他们只给你一点点，你一开始只喝一小口。
You just have your one appointment, see if it fits and if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
您只需进行一次预约，看看它是否合适，如果不合适，您将其寄回并获得下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be, he used to be a mess.
他曾经是，他曾经是一团糟。
now he's all he's doing great.
现在他所做的一切都很棒。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days those were dark days.
你在鲁拉之前的日子里认识我，那是黑暗的日子。
I don't wish you would pre-rule on anyone.
我不希望你对任何人做出预先裁决。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're a shining example of what can happen.
你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
Rula helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
Rula 帮助您找到真正符合您目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为您分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
even better, RULA RULA RULA works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，RULA RULA RULA 与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you're actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
Thousands of people are already using RULA to get affordable high-quality therapy that's actually covered by insurance.
成千上万的人已经在使用 RULA 来获得负担得起的高质量治疗，而且这些治疗实际上是由保险承保的。
Visit rulea.com slash your mother to get started.
访问rulea.com 砍掉你的母亲即可开始。
That's rulea-ru-l-a.com slash your mother.
这就是rulea-ru-l-a.com 砍你妈妈。
You deserve mental health care that works with you, not against your budget.
您应该得到适合您的心理健康护理，而不是违反您的预算。
Hey, Ale.
嘿，艾尔。
Josh, remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
乔什，还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds, your face would be covered with your finger.
他们几乎统治了附近的游泳池和游乐场，你的脸会被手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five-hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, fireworks-freeze energy shot.
嗯，《五小时能量》将这种标志性的怀旧情绪重新演绎成大胆、清爽、烟花般的能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion, like the original pops of which you speak, expertly blending juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
每一口都会带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像您所说的原始流行音乐一样，巧妙地混合了多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，完全点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar so you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的零糖果味，这样您就可以毫无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, this portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决午后在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework-freez flavored 5-hour energy shot now available online at 5hourenergy.com or Amazon.
现在可在 5hourenergy.com 或 Amazon 上购买烟花口味的 5 小时能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I always love the tapery.
我永远喜欢挂毯。
I always loved, you know, you grab like a little bit of melon, maybe a bagel, a little and you sit down, you just be so relaxed.
我一直喜欢，你知道，你抓起一点瓜，也许是百吉饼，一点点，然后你坐下来，你就这么放松。
And especially the more you do it, you're so relaxed at the table.
尤其是你做得越多，你在餐桌上就越放松。
Yeah, you guys were uniquely relaxed and had fun with it in a way that's not always true.
是的，你们特别放松，并且以一种并不总是如此的方式享受其中的乐趣。
To be honest, you guys were really good at that.
说实话，你们真的很擅长这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
And then, well, at some point you stop feeling like you're auditioning, and you're like, I have the gig.
然后，好吧，在某个时刻，你不再感觉自己在试镜，你会想，我得到了演出机会。
It's been on the air.
它已经在播出了。
The ratings are good.
收视率都不错。
I have the gig.
我有演出。
Really hard to recast me at this point.
在这一点上真的很难重塑我。
Yeah, really weird.
是啊，真的很奇怪。
It's season eight.
这是第八季。
So then we'd leave, but you guys stay and rewrite the script the rest of the day based on this, right?
那么我们就离开，但你们留下来并根据这一点重写当天剩下的剧本，对吗？
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
Oh, yes, we would.
哦，是的，我们会的。
You guys would be like, great.
你们会说，太棒了。
I had breakfast.
我吃过早餐。
I'm going to go.
我要走了。
I'm going to go work out.
我要去锻炼身体。
I'm going to go do things.
我要去办事了。
I'm going to be like, all right.
我会说，好吧。
We're going to be a little team in the morning, tearing our hair out.
早上我们会组成一个小团队，努力拼搏。
We would stay.
我们会留下来。
Monday nights were not always super late for the writers, but yeah, we would, we'd be there.
对于作家来说，周一晚上并不总是很晚，但是，是的，我们会的，我们会在那里。
We'd be there for dinner.
我们会在那里吃晚饭。
We'd be there going line by line, making it as good as we could, knowing that it runs through it for the next morning.
我们会一行一行地去那里，尽我们所能地把它做好，因为我们知道第二天早上它会贯穿始终。
The next.
下一个。
Well, we would get scripted.
好吧，我们会编写脚本。
Maybe that night.
也许那天晚上。
late, sometimes late, sometimes I'd wake up Tuesday morning and just see the manila envelope by my phone.
很晚，有时很晚，有时我周二早上醒来，只看到手机旁边的马尼拉信封。
Yeah.
是的。
God bless the PAs.
上帝保佑 PA。
God bless the PAs driving those scripts around LA, like a little Christmas all of us leaving around your doorstep.
上帝保佑那些在洛杉矶推动这些剧本的 PA，就像我们大家在你家门口度过的一个小圣诞节一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Wasn't it also funny?
是不是也很搞笑呢？
I hope Jason won't mind me saying this, but sometimes Jason during the table reads would laugh so loud at something that it was clear.
我希望杰森不会介意我这么说，但有时杰森在读表时会因为一些显而易见的事情而笑得很大声。
It was the first time he was reading it.
这是他第一次读它。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
It was very clear.
情况非常清楚。
And it was weird because it was like, oh, that was great.
这很奇怪，因为它就像，哦，那太棒了。
It's a real compliment to the work.
这是对这项工作的真正赞美。
I think maybe he should have read it by now.
我想也许他现在应该已经读过了。
But okay, like you were excited that he was laughing like that.
但是好吧，就像你因为他那样笑而感到兴奋一样。
He was clearly discovering it in the moment.
他此刻显然已经发现了这一点。
What his character was doing.
他的角色在做什么。
And giving a great, authentic, real laugh.
并发出美妙、真实、真实的笑声。
And giving a great, like cold read, yeah.
是的，进行一次很棒的冷读。
Yeah, yeah, I know he's in me, he knew we could do that, but yeah, that was, I guess, that was a thing.
是的，是的，我知道他在我心里，他知道我们可以做到这一点，但是，是的，我想，那是一件事。
Yeah.
是的。
But always a very generous laugh.
但总是很慷慨的笑。
You'd get the script and it would have asterix on the, it would be a different color pages, right?
你会得到剧本，上面会有星号，它会是不同的颜色页面，对吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And then you get the script and how the asterix where all the changes had been revision marks for the previous right.
然后你会得到脚本，以及所有更改的星号如何成为前一个右侧的修订标记。
So did you ever did your heart sink when you when you found one that was like just machine gun fire asterisks all the way down you're like, oh, well, it was really like you guys cracked it.
所以，当你发现一个像机枪射击星号一样的东西时，你的心会沉下去吗，你会想，哦，好吧，真的就像你们破解了它一样。
Like you solved the thing.
就像你解决了问题一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And other times, other times there were a few episodes where I felt like you guys were really chasing it.
有时，有时有几集我觉得你们真的在追赶它。
Like really, you had you wrote three scripts in three days.
就像真的一样，你在三天内写了三个剧本。
You know, did you ever get one and you're like, really no asterisks here?
你知道，你有没有得到过一个，然后你会想，这里真的没有星号吗？
You're sticking with that one.
你坚持那个。
But there were also there were also, um, you go through and you, you kind of feel like, Oh, maybe I, Oh, I blew that joke and now that joke is gone.
但也有，嗯，你经历过，你有点感觉，哦，也许我，哦，我搞砸了那个笑话，现在那个笑话消失了。
Like sometimes you get self-conscious.
就像有时你会变得自我意识一样。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, like I thought I didn't blow that joke.
好吧，就像我以为我没有开那个玩笑一样。
Why is that joke gone?
那个笑话怎么没了？
The, oh, well, I would say nine times out of ten, it's just writer self-hatred.
哦，好吧，我想说十有八九，这只是作家的自我憎恨。
It's just writers going the joke was no good.
只是编剧开个玩笑而已，没什么好处。
It would be like, if you'd like slightly fumble the joke, but it was good.
就好像，如果你想稍微讲点笑话，但这很好。
We knew it.
我们知道。
We would leave it in.
我们会把它留在里面。
I think it's It was probably much more direct.
我认为这可能更直接。
It was never.
从来没有。
It was never too much.
这从来都不是太多。
Most of the time, it was an upgrade, like it was really, especially.
大多数时候，这是一次升级，就像真的一样，特别是。
So we would get the script.
这样我们就可以拿到剧本了。
You drive back to the FoxOT, like around, I don't know, 9 or 10, we'd start, I think we started a little earlier on Tuesdays, 9 or 13.
你开车回到 FoxOT，大约是，我不知道，9 点或 10 点左右，我们会开始，我想我们在星期二，9 点或 13 点开始得早一些。
Yeah.
是的。
9 I think we're rehearsing until kind of lunchtime run through.
9 我想我们正在排练直到午餐时间结束。
Yeah.
是的。
So that's just Pam and the cast and, you know, the props, they're all kicking around.
所以只有帕姆和演员们，还有道具，他们都在忙着。
The stage is buzzing, but you basically, we all clock down in the living room.
舞台上很热闹，但基本上，我们都在客厅打卡。
We'd read the script, we'd read the rewrite, Pam would have us read it and then she would get us on our feet And we'd start staging it.
我们会读剧本，我们会读重写，帕姆会让我们读它，然后她会让我们站起来，然后我们就开始上演。
Sometimes you or Carter were there for that initial one if there were like a lot of rewrites But mostly you just let us do it, right?
有时，如果有很多重写，你或卡特就会在那里进行最初的修改，但大多数情况下你只是让我们这样做，对吗？
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
We didn't want to be we didn't want to be in the way over thinking the words You guys had to get it in your bodies and start moving it through space and stuff.
我们不想成为我们不想妨碍思考“你们必须把它放入你们的身体并开始在空间和其他东西中移动它”这句话。
So Pam would stage the whole thing for, you know, then we'd have lunch.
所以帕姆会把整个事情安排好，然后我们就吃午饭。
And then after lunch, the stage would, all the writers, studio executives, network executives, all the department heads, all, everyone would descend upon the stage.
然后午饭后，舞台上，所有的编剧，工作室主管，网络主管，所有部门负责人，所有，每个人都会走上舞台。
And we would run through at around 1230 or one.
我们会在 1230 点左右跑完。
Yeah.
是的。
And we'd run through the whole show.
我们会看完整个演出。
And I remember Pam would say, all right, follow me down to the bar.
我记得帕姆会说，好吧，跟我到酒吧去。
All the sets lined up on the stage.
所有的布景都在舞台上一字排开。
All the sets.
所有的集。
And then we'd, we'd walk set to set.
然后我们就按部就班地走。
And the show had so many cuts that that sometimes people were like, God, there's a lot of walking in there.
这部剧有太多剪辑，有时人们会想，天啊，里面有很多人走。
All the little cars.
所有的小汽车。
And some men's pan would say, we're not moving.
有些男人会说，我们不会搬家。
We're just going to stay here.
我们就待在这里。
Pretend this is the bar.
假装这是酒吧。
We're going to sit down.
我们要坐下来。
It's just two lines.
这只是两条线。
We're going to sit down.
我们要坐下来。
Pretend these two chairs are the bar.
假设这两把椅子是吧台。
That's like a year or two to figure out that we needed to like, because by the end of some of these executives, by the end of the run through, some of these guys are executives were like sweating.
这大约需要一两年的时间才能弄清楚我们需要喜欢什么，因为在这些高管中的一些人结束时，在运行结束时，其中一些人是高管，他们都在流汗。
But we want them to be happy.
但我们希望他们幸福。
They have their cardio in it or run through.
他们有氧运动在其中或贯穿其中。
To picture what we're talking about here, you have a very large stage, stage 22.
为了想象我们在这里讨论的内容，你有一个非常大的舞台，第 22 阶段。
And just imagine just what you've, everyone listening has probably seen a set of television, but you have the hero set of the couch, but then just imagine this in the gigantic warehouse, 10, 12, 15 of these little sets.
想象一下你所看到的，每个听众可能都看过一套电视，但你有沙发上的主角，但想象一下在巨大的仓库里，有 10、12、15 个这样的小电视机。
You've got the dentist office, you got this, you got that, you got the small things, which have been built in a day, a couple of days, and then have to be dismantled and replaced with another set often from Wednesday to Thursday, once it's shot out on Wednesday.
你有牙医诊所，你有这个，你有那个，你有一些小东西，这些东西是在一天、几天内建成的，然后必须在周三到周四拆除并更换另一套，一旦周三被射出。
So it was really our crew, our production crew was unbelievable.
所以这确实是我们的工作人员，我们的制作人员令人难以置信。
The only sets that were there and never got touched were the bar and the apartment.
唯一在那里但从未被触及的布景是酒吧和公寓。
That's it.
就是这样。
Those two were always there.
那两个人一直都在。
And hilariously, they're right next door to each other.
有趣的是，他们就在隔壁。
They're literally butted up against each other.
他们实际上是互相对抗的。
That is funny.
这很有趣。
It's the only way.
这是唯一的办法。
You could basically walk from one end to the other.
您基本上可以从一端走到另一端。
It's right there, right there.
就在那里，就在那里。
Everything else would change out, and the run through would move to these sets, and sometimes the sets were only half built, but we'd be pretending we were fully built during the run through.
其他一切都会改变，并且贯穿将转移到这些集合，有时这些集合只构建了一半，但我们会假装我们在贯穿过程中已完全构建。
It was a lot of work.
这是很多工作。
So we would do the run through and you'd hear what was working you'd feel what wasn't quite working and then you guys would huddle up With the networking studio executives right in the writers.
所以我们会进行一次运行，你会听到什么是有效的，你会感觉到什么不太有效，然后你们会和网络工作室的高管挤在一起，就在编剧中。
Yeah, we would go home.
是的，我们会回家。
We would be home We do I'd leave it one or one thirty on a Tuesday and have the rest of my day my day was just beginning.
我们会回家。我们会回家的。我会在周二凌晨一点或三十分回家，然后度过剩下的一天，我的一天才刚刚开始。
Yeah Yeah, we'd be given notes by our our executives and often very very smart notes We really we gave ourselves the most notes So, you know, we went back, there was stuff we wanted to change.
是的，我们的高管会给我们做笔记，而且通常都是非常非常聪明的笔记。我们确实给自己做了最多的笔记。所以，你知道，我们回去了，有一些我们想要改变的东西。
Like, we'd stay late, not because it was like considered a disaster, just because we were like, camera's roll tomorrow morning, we want to, let's use this time, let's make this as good as we can make it.
就像，我们会熬夜，不是因为这被认为是一场灾难，只是因为我们想，明天早上相机胶卷，我们想，让我们利用这段时间，让我们尽我们所能把它做到最好。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was it.
就是这样。
But did we go rewrite to late at night?
但我们重写到深夜了吗？
And that script would go out, three in the morning on a Wednesday, and it would get to you.
那个剧本会在周三凌晨三点发出，然后你就会收到。
And the production assistants would drive it to our house, right?
制作助理会把它开到我们家，对吗？
They would drive it to your house, because like, and maybe later in the run, we finally went email attachments exist.
他们会把它开到你家，因为就像，也许在运行的后期，我们终于发现了电子邮件附件的存在。
It's not 1925, like we could, but I remember somewhere near the end going like, maybe these these poor PAs don't need to be driving.
这不是 1925 年，就像我们可以的那样，但我记得在接近尾声的某个地方，也许这些可怜的 PA 不需要开车。
But it was for many years of a hard copy show.
但这是多年来的硬拷贝节目。
It was a hard hit.
这是一个沉重的打击。
Most of the run.
大部分都是跑的。
And I think even at the end when we said we're going to switch to emails, I think a few people, a few holdouts were like, I still want to trip into my house.
我认为即使最后当我们说我们要改用电子邮件时，我想有些人，一些坚持不懈的人会说，我仍然想走进我的房子。
I like getting the hard copy.
我喜欢拿到硬拷贝。
And the PAs were like, oh god damn it.
PA 的反应是，哦，该死的。
So then you guys would rewrite all night.
然后你们就整夜重写。
We'd get the new script.
我们会得到新的剧本。
So Wednesday morning, sometimes before I left the house, if I had some time, I would look through.
所以周三早上，有时在我离开家之前，如果我有时间，我会仔细查看。
just looking at the start changes because by that point you know the script pretty well and you're just looking for what's changed because you're going to have to shoot it maybe that day.
只是看看开始的变化，因为到那时你已经非常了解剧本了，你只是在寻找变化的地方，因为你可能必须在那天拍摄它。
So we come in Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
所以我们周三、周四、周五来。
We blocked and shot the entire show.
我们封锁并拍摄了整个节目。
We a lot of people don't know this.
我们很多人都不知道这一点。
I don't know if we talked about this.
我不知道我们是否讨论过这个问题。
We never shot in front of a live studio audience where you know, where would you put the bleachers?
我们从来没有在现场演播室观众面前拍摄，你知道，你会把露天看台放在哪里？
There's too many damn sets.
该死的套路太多了
So for three days we would make the show Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
因此，在三天的时间里，我们将在周三、周四、周五进行演出。
And also this is another reason and why sit comes.
这也是坐的另一个原因。
If you can get one, it's a great way to raise a family because you get one week off a month.
如果你能得到一个，这是养家糊口的好方法，因为你每个月可以休息一周。
We only do, we do three weeks on one week off.
我们只做三周，休息一周。
Yeah.
是的。
Which was pretty cozy, pretty civilized compared to the hours that the writers also worked that week.
与编剧们那周的工作时间相比，这相当舒适、相当文明。
You stun up a bitch.
你把一个婊子惊呆了。
Sorry.
对不起。
I remember one, one time, I don't, it was not you, but somebody was the summer.
我记得有一次，我不记得了，那不是你，而是某个人，那是夏天。
It was the end of the summer.
那是夏末。
When we were all coming back to start shooting was like, you know, mid August or late August, whenever we start to back up.
当我们都回来开始拍摄时，你知道，八月中旬或八月底，每当我们开始备份时。
And I remember one of one of you guys, one of the actors wasn't you asked me like, you know, what did you do?
我记得你们其中一位演员，其中一位演员不是你问我，你知道，你做了什么？
I was in Europe.
我当时在欧洲。
I was here.
我到过这里。
What did you do all summer?
整个夏天你都做了什么？
And I was like, we wrote this shit.
我当时想，我们写了这个狗屎。
That's what we did.
这就是我们所做的。
We, I have not seen the sun.
我们，我还没有见过太阳。
I look pale.
我看起来脸色苍白。
I look like sick ET at the end of the movie.
电影结尾时我看起来就像生病的外星人。
I don't, I have not been outside during daylight, but I'm glad you enjoyed your trip.
我没有，我白天没有出去过，但我很高兴你旅途愉快。
No, I always came back refreshed.
不，我总是神清气爽地回来。
I always came back refreshed.
我总是神清气爽地回来。
You guys always came back looking so beautiful in tan.
你们回来时总是穿着棕褐色的衣服，看起来很漂亮。
and we're like, haggard limping into the start of the marathon, but it was, no, it was, it was awesome.
我们就像，憔悴地一瘸一拐地进入马拉松比赛的开始，但它是，不，它是，这太棒了。
And we would always come in six, eight scripts ahead and we'd bust our asses that during the summer.
我们总是会提前准备六、八个剧本，并且在夏天我们会拼尽全力。
And we got a little, we got a little six week, four weeks, six week in the spring off the writers desk.
我们在春天从作家的办公桌上得到了一点，我们得到了六个星期，四个星期，六个星期。
Yeah.
是的。
We had a chance on set because sometimes Mike Shay, our first AD, who's a gem, hello, Michael.
我们在片场有机会，因为有时迈克·谢伊，我们的第一位广告人，他是一个宝石，你好，迈克尔。
We love you if you're listening.
如果你在听，我们爱你。
But he would talk us through the schedule and he'd say, you know, if we can do some real good professional acting on Thursday, we can be out by lunch.
但他会告诉我们时间表，他会说，你知道，如果我们周四能做一些真正出色的专业表演，我们就可以在午餐时出去。
I always say out by lunch.
我总是说午饭前出去。
Out by lunch?
吃午饭就出去吗？
No, but I start, I remember I started a champ out by lunch and we would all just like turn into Lord of the Flies.
不，但我开始了，我记得我在午餐时就开始了冠军之旅，我们都想变成蝇王。
Out by Lungling Carrot.
被猛龙胡萝卜出局。
Lungling Carrot.
龙龙胡萝卜。
OBL, we called it.
OBL，我们称之为。
OBL.
OBL。
Yeah.
是的。
You did.
你做到了。
And you knew it was a squid.
你知道那是鱿鱼。
We did work until late, late, late.
我们一直工作到很晚、很晚、很晚。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
And there was outside night shoots.
还有室外夜景拍摄。
You guys had some very late nights and we shot the, we shot a lot of scenes in this TV show.
你们度过了一些很晚的夜晚，我们拍摄了这个电视节目中的很多场景。
And it was, it was a, the Wednesday to Friday was huge for a lot of you guys.
周三到周五对于很多人来说都是很重要的。
Yeah.
是的。
Most weeks.
大多数星期。
And talk a little bit about New York Street, the one thing that, the, the, the, the other main area that is not inside stage 22.
谈谈纽约街，这是不在第 22 阶段内的另一个主要区域。
It's smaller than people think New York Street on the, on the, what was on the Fox lot.
它比人们想象的纽约街福克斯停车场上的地方要小。
I guess it's now the Disney lot is a, um, it's tiny, right?
我想现在的迪士尼乐园很小，对吧？
Josh, it's like a little, little block, little block like with a little mini turn in it.
乔什，它就像一个小块，小块，里面有一个小转弯。
It's like a little, like a two Ls, put two Ls, yeah, and it's, we milked the shit out of that thing for nine years to make it look like so many different brands in New York.
就像一点点，就像两个 L，加上两个 L，是的，我们花了九年时间从那个东西中榨取了屎，使它看起来像纽约的许多不同品牌。
By the end of it, it was like, there's no molecule we haven't shot.
到最后，就好像我们没有射出任何分子。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
I always like shooting on New York Street.
我一直喜欢在纽约街头拍摄。
It always felt like a field trip.
总感觉像是一次实地考察。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Me too.
我也是。
It did.
确实如此。
It felt special.
感觉很特别。
Like a field trip.
就像实地考察一样。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
Yeah.
是的。
We're getting out of school.
我们要放学了
Yeah.
是的。
And also, I always, they always would offer to give me a ride, but I always like walking down to New York Street.
而且，我总是，他们总是愿意载我一程，但我总是喜欢步行到纽约街。
Yeah.
是的。
Like it felt like a nice little just head clearing.
感觉就像是一次很好的头脑清醒。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was a nice little walk.
这是一次愉快的散步。
feed five to a minute walk to New York street and was right up at the front of the Fox lot and you'd be standing in this little cute, like sort of little Italy-like lock, right?
步行五到分钟即可到达纽约街，就在福克斯停车场的前面，你会站在这个可爱的小锁里，就像意大利的小锁一样，对吧？
It was obviously in Mulberry Street.
显然是在桑树街。
And then you'd look, this cognitive dissonance would happen and where you'd look one direction and see New York in the other direction and see like palm trees and a blue sky and people walking by.
然后你会发现，这种认知失调会发生，你朝一个方向看，却在另一个方向看到纽约，看到棕榈树、蓝天和路过的人们。
For the place, it was always very strange.
对于这个地方来说，总是很陌生。
You sometimes lost track where you were, sometimes I felt like I was really there in New York.
有时你会迷失自己在哪里，有时我感觉自己真的在纽约。
It was a great, we really made the most of that little street, my God.
真是太棒了，我们真的充分利用了那条小街，天啊。
But there was something about New York Street that made me feel like old Hollywood like Cecil B.
但纽约街的某些东西让我感觉自己像塞西尔·B.
DeMille.
德米尔.
Absolutely.
绝对地。
Like there was something so grand and fun and fake, but not fake about it.
就像有什么东西如此宏伟、有趣、虚假，但并不虚假。
Like it was really cool.
好像真的很酷。
Yeah.
是的。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
It felt like PB's big adventure.
这感觉就像是 PB 的大冒险。
Like that big piece of blood where it was like it gave you the Hollywood you wanted as a kid.
就像那一大块血一样，它给了你小时候想要的好莱坞。
Yes.
是的。
I think you were going to be part of one day.
我想有一天你会成为其中的一部分。
Exactly.
确切地。
Yeah.
是的。
That's also where Todd runs down the street, but we'll get to that later and I don't remember that over time.
这也是托德沿着街道跑步的地方，但我们稍后会讲到，随着时间的推移我不记得了。
and we're going to get to that.
我们将会做到这一点。
We're going to wait until that's going to talk about that.
我们要等到那个时候再讨论这个问题。
Amazing, thank you for that.
太棒了，谢谢你。
That is illuminating it, I think, of how this goes.
我认为这说明了事情是如何进行的。
And we'll keep going back to that sort of bigger questions.
我们将继续回到此类更大的问题。
I want to ask about the writer's room.
我想问一下作家的房间。
I want to ask about all sorts of things.
我想问各种各样的事情。
Let's do a few question number two, I guess.
我想，让我们做一些第二个问题。
We're just a couple of quick ones here.
我们只是这里的几个快速人员。
A lot of people have questions about where ideas come from and obviously there's the simple answer of, well, we're writers.
很多人都对想法从何而来有疑问，显然有一个简单的答案：我们是作家。
We think of not me.
我们想的不是我。
We think of them.
我们想到他们。
We come up with ideas and then we rewrite them on a piece of paper.
我们提出想法，然后将它们重写在纸上。
You however Craig have said many times that you took from people's lives, whether from the writers themselves who said, oh, this happened to me or from your friends and you told them about it or you didn't tell them about it.
然而克雷格已经说过很多次你从人们的生活中夺走了东西，无论是从作家自己那里，他们说，哦，这件事发生在我身上，还是从你的朋友那里，你告诉他们这件事，或者你没有告诉他们。
We'll get to that as time goes on.
随着时间的推移我们会解决这个问题。
So there's a category of question that is, how did you come up with?
所以有一类问题是，你是怎么想出来的？
So many people want to know about the idea of picking up girls at the airport.
很多人想知道去机场接女孩的想法。
Do you recall where this notion came from?
你还记得这个想法是从哪里来的吗？
If you're implying that I did this, the answer is no.
如果你暗示这是我做的，那么答案是否定的。
I'm not I literally think it was just a pun that we liked in the writer's room.
我不是，我真的认为这只是我们在作家房间里喜欢的双关语。
I think it was just the reveal that he's going to pick up girls.
我认为这只是他要泡妞的消息。
It just worked.
它刚刚起作用了。
It was just a great little wordplay joke and we did it.
这只是一个很棒的双关语笑话，我们做到了。
There was nothing.
什么也没有。
There was no real story.
没有真实的故事。
Every now and again, something's just funny.
时不时地，有些事情很有趣。
That was just funny.
这真有趣。
It made us laugh.
这让我们笑了。
So we did it.
所以我们做到了。
It also feels like Barney looks at every setting in the world and thinks how do you pick up girls here?
感觉巴尼看着世界上的每一个地方，并思考如何在这里泡妞？
And he just has a scheme for every one.
他只是为每个人制定了一个计划。
And this is his airport scheme.
这是他的机场计划。
This is his airport scheme.
And he's apparently been doing it long enough that there's a ton of security camera footage of him doing it.
显然他已经这样做了足够长的时间，以至于有大量的监控录像记录了他这样做的情况。
Yeah, and I loved, I guess the emotion I liked behind it is just how pathetic it kind of is.
是的，我喜欢，我想我喜欢它背后的情感就是它是多么可悲。
My favorite thing about Barney and rewatching it is just like, he's such a broken man.
关于巴尼，我最喜欢的一点是，重看它就像，他是一个如此破碎的人。
He's like, you know what I mean?
他就像，你知道我的意思吗？
He's just like in this episode too.
他也像这一集中一样。
He's just like, go along with my idea Ted.
他就像是，同意我的想法，特德。
Show me that I'm important.
让我知道我很重要。
Show me that I'm special.
让我知道我很特别。
I find it like so like poignant and moving in a way to watch how needy Barney is in these early episodes like more so than I remember.
我觉得在某种程度上，看到巴尼在这些早期剧集中的贫困程度比我记忆中的还要强烈，这让人心酸又感动。
I haven't watched these ones in a while and he just wants Ted to think his idea is cool and go along with it.
我有一段时间没看过这些了，他只是想让泰德认为他的想法很酷并同意它。
That's it.
就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
He just wants Ted's approval.
他只是想要特德的认可。
I had the experience watching it where I felt like I wish Ted was a little more game and I wish Barney would be a little less excited.
我在观看比赛时有过这样的经历，我觉得我希望泰德能多一点比赛，而我希望巴尼能少一点兴奋。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I know that's where the drama comes from, but just like watching almost like me or this avatar of me, I was like, you should go along with this.
就像我知道这就是戏剧的来源一样，但就像观看几乎像我或我的化身一样，我想，你应该同意这一点。
This could be fun.
这可能很有趣。
I mean, not when he's drinking Mike's hard lemonade in the basement, you know, at that point, he's over it.
我的意思是，不是当他在地下室喝迈克的硬柠檬水时，你知道，那时他就已经喝完了。
But yeah, I mean, I think, I think we got there more later.
但是，是的，我的意思是，我想，我想我们到达那里的时间更长。
I think we got there more later.
我想我们后来才到达那里。
We got there more later.
后来我们又到了那里。
He can have fun with us too.
他也可以和我们一起玩得很开心。
He realizes some of the best nights of his life are created by this madman, and it's better to just go along with them.
他意识到他一生中最美好的一些夜晚都是这个疯子创造的，最好顺其自然。
Yeah.
是的。
What I was struck with was, is Barney successful at doing this?
让我震惊的是，巴尼成功做到了这一点吗？
Like, that's what I, I feel like later in this series, you get the sense that he is, he is, he does get, he does get the ladies.
就像，这就是我，我在这个系列后面的感觉，你会感觉到他是，他是，他确实得到了，他确实得到了女士们。
But in this one, I was like, oh, early on, it's possible he doesn't.
但在这一次，我想，哦，一开始，他可能不会。
It's possible.
这是有可能的。
These are all just games that play.
这些都只是玩的游戏。
In episode one, he's playing laser tag with preteens.
在第一集中，他正在和青春期前的孩子玩激光枪战。
In episode two, he seems to hook up with one girl in those series of parties.
在第二集中，他似乎在一系列聚会中勾搭上了一个女孩。
In episode three, he's just back to just not really, not really scoring any with any ladies.
在第三集中，他只是回到了不真正、没有真正与任何女士得分的状态。
He's not really doing anything that impressive.
他并没有真正做任何令人印象深刻的事情。
Sometimes you see him with an actual woman.
有时你会看到他和一个真正的女人在一起。
But a lot of times it's just a story, he's telling I think it's yeah, and I would guess that 75 to 80% of his stories are either fabricated or a kernel of truth, you know, kernel of truth, that's the bonus one, that's the bonus one.
但很多时候这只是一个故事，他在讲，我认为是的，我猜他的故事 75% 到 80% 要么是捏造的，要么是事实的核心，你知道，事实的核心，这是额外的，这是额外的。
We got there.
我们到了那里。
That's why you remember?
这就是你记得的原因？
Yes.
是的。
We initiated general knowledge.
我们启动了常识。
We said we're going to get to this one, and it is fucking happened.
我们说过我们会解决这个问题，而它确实发生了。
No, unplanned.
不，计划外的。
That was just too.
那也是。
You are lucky you are listening to this kind of stuff.
你很幸运你正在听这样的东西。
I felt my way to that just intuitively.
我凭直觉感觉到了这一点。
Colonel of knowledge.
知识上校。
Colonel of truth.
真理上校。
Colonel of knowledge, yeah.
知识上校，是的。
Does it good?
好用吗？
Does it?
是吗？
When you find those in nature, it's just so good.
当你在大自然中找到这些时，那就太好了。
Okay.
好的。
What else?
还有什么？
I forgot we're talking about the next question.
我忘了我们正在讨论下一个问题。
Well, I think people really loved the interrogation scene because there were multiple questions.
嗯，我认为人们真的很喜欢审讯场景，因为有很多问题。
Alex, that scene is so funny.
亚历克斯，那个场景真有趣。
It's so good.
太好了。
it, uh, mad, candy, what?
它，呃，疯狂，糖果，什么？
Oh, mad, mad candy, hatter and hazard Hansen for questions like this.
噢，疯狂、疯狂的糖果、帽匠和危险汉森，问了这样的问题。
How many takes it?
有多少人需要它？
How many takes did it take for you in Neil in the police room scene?
《尼尔》警察室场景你拍了多少遍？
Or how hard it was it for you to not break on set?
或者说，在片场不休息对你来说有多难？
People obviously love bloopers.
人们显然喜欢花哨的事情。
They also just love hearing about the notion of bloopers.
他们也喜欢听到花哨的概念。
And so hard to fashion a real question around this.
围绕这个问题很难提出一个真正的问题。
But well, it looked like you were having fun.
不过，看起来你玩得很开心。
Were you, were you breaking a lot.
你是吗，你打破了很多吗？
I think that that's a pretty strong blooper presence in episode what season one bloopers.
我认为在第一季的花絮中，这是一个相当强烈的花絮。
Yeah.
是的。
Because Neil, he definitely was making me laugh with we are international just doubling and tripling and quadrupling down on that.
因为尼尔，他肯定让我笑了，我们是国际化的，只是在这方面加倍、三倍、四倍的投入。
I do remember in the run-throughs and even when we were shooting it, the thing about the shirt, you know, the untucked shirt and his looks to me.
我确实记得在演练中，甚至在我们拍摄的时候，关于衬衫的事情，你知道，衬衫没有塞进裤腰，还有他对我的看法。
And I felt like, I felt like we were, like, Laurel and Hardy or Avin Costello.
我觉得，我觉得我们就像劳雷尔和哈代或艾文·科斯特洛。
Ron Trip movie.
罗恩·特里普电影。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
It was just like, it felt like we were a new kind of, like, classic Vaudeville team, definitely.
就好像，感觉我们绝对是一种新的、经典的杂耍团队。
Yeah.
是的。
Where we were just had a bit and he had his character and I had my character.
我们只是聊了一会儿，他有他的性格，我有我的性格。
You know, it was really interesting to see Ted, like, in the first two episodes, Ted is the driver, like he's got his foot on the accelerator.
你知道，看到泰德真的很有趣，就像在前两集中，泰德是司机，就像他的脚踩在油门上一样。
And in this one, he's a reactor.
在这一次，他是一个反应堆。
Barney is the driver, you know.
你知道，巴尼是司机。
And I think I was, I was really trying to navigate how to be like, I think, if I was directing myself again, I would have been like, lighten this up.
我想我真的在努力寻找如何成为这样的人，我想，如果我再次指导自己，我会像，减轻这一切。
Like it's a little, like I was a little too bummed.
好像有点，好像我有点太沮丧了。
And I just wish I had had like a little smile.
我只希望我有一个小小的微笑。
I think it's a great look.
我认为这看起来很棒。
We can fix it in post.
我们可以在后期修复它。
It's not too heavy.
不太重。
We can get back in it.
我们可以回到其中。
I think I was too bummed out by him.
我觉得我太被他气坏了。
And I think I should just been like, you know, some That's the writing though as you point out because we could we could have written that I agree with that I agree with that as a writing note to look we could have and I think we found that I think we're like We found out where we went on but it's a little exaggerated in this one because you had to you had to figure out Why do they keep paying out with this guy?
我想我应该就像，你知道，有些就像你指出的那样，因为我们可以写出我同意我同意作为一个书面笔记来看看我们可以有，我想我们发现我想我们就像我们发现了我们继续前进的地方，但这有点夸张，因为你必须弄清楚为什么他们继续与这个人付款？
Yeah, well the last line of the narration of the episode does sort of fit to that Which is great and that was that was the question we were trying to answer in the episode It was like why do they hang out with this guy?
是的，这一集叙述的最后一行确实符合这一点，这很棒，这就是我们在这一集中试图回答的问题，就像他们为什么和这个家伙一起出去玩？
And that was the answer at the end of that episode Yeah, but I'm or Chris and Phil Chris Miller filled or wonderful writers wrote that episode.
这就是那集结尾的答案是的，但我或克里斯和菲尔克里斯·米勒充满或出色的作家写了那集。
They would they would refer to it as the way they when they want to Descript, they said we're going to write this as a Barney cartoon.
他们会按照他们想要描述的方式来称呼它，他们说我们要把它写成巴尼卡通。
That was the phrase that always second man We're going to write a Barney cartoon.
这就是第二个人总是说的一句话：我们要写一部巴尼漫画。
They're these they're they're the men the brilliant minds who brought you the Lego movies and cloudy The test people so they are cartoon guys there are animation guys and they said is it okay if we push Barney to this place of being this cartoon Ted gets sucked into it and it's like he's sort of the voice of reason within he's sort of the human being interacting with an animated character.
他们是这些人，他们是那些给你带来乐高电影和多云测试的聪明人，所以他们是卡通人，还有动画人，他们说，如果我们把巴尼推到这个卡通人物的地方，泰德被卷入其中，就好像他是一个与动画角色互动的人类中的理性声音。
And they push that, they sort of, that's where we first got legendary.
他们推动了这一点，这就是我们第一次获得传奇的地方。
That's where we got the lactose intolerant joke.
这就是我们得到乳糖不耐症笑话的地方。
That's that script is where we got all that stuff.
这就是我们获得所有这些东西的脚本。
And Barney climbing out of the suitcase that he zipped himself into on the baggage claim.
巴尼从行李箱里爬出来，在行李认领处把自己拉上拉链。
And apparently that worked, apparently that got him the girl.
显然这很有效，显然这让他得到了那个女孩。
But is that actually the truth who knows?
但这真的是事实吗？谁知道呢？
I do want to know the backstory of what he said to the woman about why he was inside the suitcase.
我确实想知道他对那个女人说的关于他为什么在手提箱里的背景故事。
But that's the beginning of his master of disguise.
但这就是他伪装大师的开始。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
And then really they ran with that they just made it a cartoon and it was also great how you guys be to pay off legend wait for it and I hope you're not lactose intolerant because the next part of this phrase is dairy and whatever I don't know if I'm missing out of that right.
然后他们真的就这样说，他们只是把它拍成了一部动画片，你们能回报传奇的等待也很棒，我希望你们没有乳糖不耐症，因为这句话的下一部分是乳制品，我不知道我是否错过了这一权利。
But you said legendary about 12 to 15 times to set that up like yeah it was literally just it's really saying legendary to set up that last punch line.
但是你说了大约 12 到 15 次传奇来设置这个，是的，它确实是说传奇来设置最后一个妙语。
It really is it's all there to get to that joke Yeah.
确实，这一切都是为了开那个玩笑 是的。
It's all there to get to that joke.
这一切都是为了讲那个笑话。
And then that became this catchphrase for Barney that sort of echoed through eternity, but it was really, yeah, you're right.
然后这成为巴尼的口号，在永恒中回响，但它确实是，是的，你是对的。
We wrote that as setups to get to that one joke.
我们写这个是为了达到那个笑话的目的。
And then it took off because I don't know if he said legendary in the first two episodes.
然后它就开始流行了，因为我不知道他在前两集中是否说过传奇。
He definitely didn't.
他绝对没有。
Because I feel like Chris and Phil brought that in with them by writing their Barney cartoon.
因为我觉得克里斯和菲尔通过写他们的巴尼卡通片带入了这一点。
I feel like that was very much them.
我觉得这就是他们。
And that lactose and tolerance joke was very much.
乳糖和耐受性的笑话非常多。
I mean, their names are on the script, obviously, but it's very They're also very collaborative, but they really came in with a lot of that sort of fun Barney speak.
我的意思是，他们的名字显然在剧本上，但他们也非常合作，但他们确实带来了很多有趣的巴尼演讲。
They really helped define that in the show.
他们确实在节目中帮助定义了这一点。
I'll be forever grateful to them for that.
我将永远感激他们。
Didn't they also bring in the term mind hole?
他们不是还引入了“心灵洞”这个词吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I think mind hole.
我觉得脑子有洞。
They had their own language.
他们有自己的语言。
Chris and Phil had their own language.
克里斯和菲尔有自己的语言。
There's a few lines in that episode where I'm just like only Chris and Phil, where he's like Barney asked the guy, like, do you ever touch the Liberty Bell and the guy goes, only all the time.
在那一集里有几句台词，我就像克里斯和菲尔一样，他就像巴尼问那个人，比如，你有没有碰过自由钟，然后那个人就一直走了。
That's like the first only all the time.
这就像一直以来的第一个。
I'm like, that's Chris and Phil.
我想，那是克里斯和菲尔。
I can't tell you why only all the time.
我只能一直告诉你为什么。
I love it so much.
我非常喜欢它。
Can I say I know there were a lot of questions about licking Liberty Bell and we don't know.
我可以说我知道有很多关于舔自由钟的问题，但我们不知道。
I don't know where that came from, but I did write a tweet I think years ago.
我不知道那是从哪里来的，但我记得几年前我确实写过一条推文。
This is many years ago while the show was still on, where I said, I'm genuinely curious how many security guards at the Liberty Bell have had to stop himium fans from trying to lick it or throwing them out for licking it, because there had to have been an increase at the very least in attempts from zero percent to semi-requited.
这是很多年前的事了，当时节目还在播出，我说过，我真的很好奇自由钟有多少保安不得不阻止那些想舔它的粉丝，或者因为舔它而把他们扔出去，因为至少尝试的次数必须从零增加到半回报。
Like a couple, they have to, right?
就像情侣一样，他们必须这样做，对吗？
Like I'm so curious, we should get a Liberty Bell security guard as a guest.
就像我很好奇一样，我们应该邀请自由钟保安作为客人。
So just can we invite any fans to write us?
那么我们可以邀请粉丝给我们写信吗？
you know, right, right as if they ever got, if anyone would ever lick those Liberty Bell.
你知道，对，就好像他们曾经得到过，如果有人愿意舔那些自由钟的话。
We want to hear from you.
我们希望收到您的来信。
Yeah.
是的。
I feel like I've sought some tweets at some point where people claim to have actually done it.
我觉得我在某些时候寻找过一些人们声称实际上已经做到了的推文。
Like they knew somebody that worked there and they, they had their, they wanted to go do the how I met your mother thing and they did it.
就像他们认识在那里工作的人一样，他们，他们有他们的，他们想去做我如何认识你母亲的事情，他们做到了。
I feel like I saw a couple of people that did do it somehow.
我觉得我看到有几个人确实以某种方式做到了这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
I feel like, I mean, we both would have to and so wouldn't want to ask for proof.
我觉得，我的意思是，我们都必须这样做，所以不想要求证据。
Yeah.
是的。
I guess the problem is.
我想问题是。
Well, I also think it's another, like Barney is addicted to novelty, right?
嗯，我也认为这是另一个，就像巴尼沉迷于新奇，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
addicted to newness and weirdness and no one's ever done this before and he's a pioneer, right?
沉迷于新奇和怪异，以前没有人这样做过，他是先驱，对吧？
Like he wants to come up with the weirdest stuff.
就像他想要想出最奇怪的东西一样。
Yeah.
是的。
So he can say we did this first, you know.
所以他可以说我们先这样做了，你知道。
So I think that's quite a charming if reckless quality of him, you know.
所以我认为他的这种品质虽然鲁莽，但却非常迷人，你知道。
It's very, I found it very endearing because it's like, you know, Barney, there, Barney has some dark sides and some troubling sides but he really just wants to be spent on a special.
这非常，我发现它非常可爱，因为就像，你知道，巴尼，在那里，巴尼有一些黑暗的一面和一些令人不安的一面，但他真的只是想花在特别的事情上。
He wants to be important to his friends and also the epic part of that story did not involve having sex with women.
他想对他的朋友很重要，而且这个故事的史诗部分并不涉及与女性发生性关系。
It involved licking the Liberty Bell.
它涉及舔自由钟。
Like this very strange out there thing.
就像外面发生的这种非常奇怪的事情。
It's not always hooking up.
它并不总是连接在一起。
Sometimes it's just doing something that nobody else has ever done.
有时它只是做一些别人从未做过的事情。
Yeah, I like that too.
是的，我也喜欢这样。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, we've answered many people, of course, wanted to point it out and enjoyed pointing out this is the birthplace of legendary.
好吧，我们已经回答了很多人，当然，想要指出这一点并且很高兴指出这是传奇的诞生地。
So thank you for covering that and with the credit, I guess, to Chris and Phil for that.
因此，感谢您对此进行报道，我想这要归功于克里斯和菲尔。
Um, but finally, uh, fans do love pointing out, uh, um, breaks in logic, uh, all these many years later.
嗯，但最后，呃，粉丝们确实喜欢指出，呃，嗯，逻辑上的断裂，呃，这么多年后。
And I, I feel through those out, um, because, you know, you're, you're just writing a TV show.
我，我感受到了这些，嗯，因为，你知道，你只是在写一个电视节目。
But I, I, I, I enjoyed that Sarah Frazier 44 did say, how was their time for a beverage service on a flight from New York City?
但我，我，我，我很喜欢 Sarah Frazier 44 所说的，他们在从纽约市起飞的航班上享受饮料服务的时间怎么样？
That's actually a great question.
这实际上是一个很好的问题。
I was prepared to be annoyed by this question.
我已经准备好被这个问题惹恼了。
And I'm like, a good, great question.
我想，这是一个很好的问题。
That's a good one.
这是一件好事。
They were circling for a while.
他们绕了一圈。
Because like, they fly Marshall drives.
因为就像，他们驾驶马歇尔驾驶。
He's probably getting there before it.
他可能会先到那里。
Like, you could drive to Philly quicker that you could fly to Philly.
就像，你开车去费城比坐飞机去费城更快。
It's totally true.
这是完全正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
All right.
好的。
Busted.
被抓了。
They busted us on the drink service.
他们在饮料服务上打败了我们。
We'll take the head on that one.
我们会拿下那个人的头。
And that's it folks.
就是这样，伙计们。
Thank you so much for sending in your, your questions there on Instagram.
非常感谢您在 Instagram 上发送您的问题。
We're going to keep on soliciting those from you on Instagram.
我们将继续在 Instagram 上征求您的意见。
So if you want to send in your questions, do go there and send them to us any any final thoughts in this bonus episode of Whatever the name of this is.
因此，如果您想提出问题，请前往那里，并将任何最终想法发送给我们，无论这是什么名字。
I don't keep names of things in my head sweet taste of sweet pal sweet taste of liberty sweet taste of liberty Yeah, I don't know it was it was just it was a fun one.
我不会在脑子里记住事物的名字甜蜜朋友的甜蜜味道自由的甜蜜味道自由的甜蜜味道是的，我不知道那是什么，只是它很有趣。
It was it was a fun other move It was the one where we started to discover Barney a little more.
这是另一个有趣的举动，我们开始更多地了解巴尼。
I love how the first two the first two really felt like an hour to me Didn't we talk about that Josh?
我喜欢前两个，前两个对我来说真的感觉就像一个小时，我们不是谈论过乔希吗？
Like yeah, it really felt like they they just belong together.
是的，真的感觉他们就像属于在一起一样。
It was like an hour-long story about this guy named Ted And then this is the episode where it's like, also, there's this speed, there's this other move in this other move of this show will be this crazy guy Barney drags people on these insane adventures, and obviously we're trying to like pair up Lily and Robin and sort of show that like our ladies will hang out.
这就像一个关于这个名叫特德的家伙的长达一小时的故事，然后这一集就像是，还有这样的速度，在这个节目的另一个动作中还有另一个动作，这个疯狂的家伙巴尼拖着人们进行这些疯狂的冒险，显然我们试图让莉莉和罗宾配对，就像我们的女士们会一起出去玩的节目一样。
They're just becoming friends.
他们只是成为朋友。
Well, so I like that it was showing other moves also as the show this show starts here and it keeps widening it spotlight.
嗯，所以我喜欢它还展示了其他动作，因为这个节目从这里开始，并且它不断扩大它的聚光灯。
Yeah, you know, and you're like Carl the bartenders over here and Wendy the waitresses over here and these people.
是的，你知道，你就像这里的调酒师卡尔和这里的女服务员温迪以及这些人。
Hammond Brothers is over here like it keeps spot lighting different and it keeps expanding its universe in a really cool way and this was definitely where I think you're right you had to explain why did they hang out with this guy and it's because they never know where the night is good and also you know Ted's insistence like I just want to be with the same bar same drink same fuzzy friends right below my apartment and he's he nudges him out of his comfort zone and it's like we need friends like that.
哈蒙德兄弟在这里，它让聚光灯保持不同，它以一种非常酷的方式不断扩展它的宇宙，这绝对是我认为你是对的，你必须解释为什么他们和这个家伙一起出去玩，因为他们永远不知道哪里的夜晚是好的，而且你也知道特德的坚持，就像我只想和我公寓楼下的同一个酒吧，同一个饮料，同一个毛茸茸的朋友在一起，他把他推出了他的舒适区，就像我们需要这样的朋友一样。
Yeah, Bernie has value.
是的，伯尼有价值。
It's a good friend.
这是一个好朋友。
How We Made Your Mother is Hosted and Executive Produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何创造了你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Webb 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at Craig Thomas Writer.com and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 Craig Thomas Writer.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。